"Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of Madness"
finds Doctor Strange and the Scarlet Witch
sharing more screen time than ever before,
but what's their MCU relationship all about?
And what's different in the comics?
Spoilers for "Multiverse of Madness" ahead!
Doctor Strange and the Scarlet Witch began
their MCU tenure in an oddly similar fashion
–- introduced in the same film, and through
the same organization.
Strange's first appearance was in name only,
during "Captain America: The Winter Soldier,"
when Cap, Falcon, and Black Widow force double-agent
Jasper Sitwell to confess who HYDRA is targeting.
"Bruce Banner, Stephen Strange, anyone who
is a threat to HYDRA."
Scarlet Witch is also introduced in "Winter
Soldier," in the film's mid-credits scene.
Moving through a HYDRA base, Baron Strucker
tells a scientist about the organization's
many experiments, finally revealing their
greatest success: the twins Quicksilver and
Scarlet Witch.
The siblings are far from the confident, composed
Avengers they would one day become, but it's
clear nonetheless the innate power they possess.
By the end of "Winter Soldier," both Doctor
Strange and Scarlet have officially entered
the MCU, in both cases through HYDRA agents
discussing their grand plans.
Perhaps the biggest difference between Doctor
Strange and the Scarlet Witch is the source
and style of magic they wield.
Though both are world-class wizards, the two
climbed to that peak from opposite sides of
the magical mountain.
Strange spent his first few decades in an
entirely magic-less world.
"I do not believe in fairytales about chakras
or energy or the power of belief.
There is no such thing as spirit!"
It was only after a period of intense study
and practice that Strange learned to wield
magic, and the magic itself reflects that
organized effort.
As Kevin Feige told Comicbook.com of Strange's
magic,
Feige also compared Strange's orderly magic
with Wanda's, noting that while Strange learned
as an adult to write in the, quote, "source
code that shapes reality," Wanda gets introduced
to this unfathomable and inexplicable power,
forcing her to spend her whole adult life
trying to control its chaos, or work within
it.
Strange and Wanda both share one critically
important facet in their magical development:
an Infinity Stone.
In "Doctor Strange," the character is forced
into a rushed curriculum, graduating to Master
of the Mystic Arts somewhat by default when
Kaecilius' attacks warranted his conscription
into the war.
Likewise, Wanda was never formally educated,
merely poked and prodded by scientists in
between periods of self-study — as a child
in Sokovia and afterwards at the Avengers
Compound.
Yet both received exponential magnifications
of their powers through connection to an Infinity
Stone.
At Kamar-Taj, Strange began experimenting
with the Eye of Agamotto, later revealed to
house the Time Stone.
His proficiency with the artifact led to him
becoming its keeper, and he leaned on its
power arguably as much as he did every other
spell in his repertoire.
Likewise, HYDRA used the Mind Stone to amplify
Wanda's powers and channel them into a more
manipulatable form.
Like Wanda's power in general, the exact nature
of the Mind Stone's influence is unknown,
but "WandaVision" made it clear that the Stone
helped lead Wanda to her ultimate destiny.
The next in the long string of parallels between
Strange and Wanda is the nature of their heroism
and their place in superhero society.
Unlike the MCU's more main-stage heroes such
as Captain America, Iron Man, and Thor, neither
Wanda nor Strange have ever fit in with the
core Avengers crowd.
Strange's relationship with the Avengers is
a relatively straightforward one.
Strange has never been an Avenger, and what's
more, during "Infinity War," Stark makes Spider-Man
an official Avenger right in front of Strange
and never offers the sorcerer the same status.
Though Wanda did become an official Avenger
at the end of "Age of Ultron," her tenure
was brief and marked by active opposition
to the group.
Before joining the team, she actively fought
against them, first protesting against their
presence in Sokovia and then joining Ultron's
campaign against them.
And though she joined the Avengers in 2015's
"Age of Ultron," she left by 2016's "Captain
America: Civil War."
Fighting against Iron Man's registered Avengers,
she became a fugitive from the law and then
a prisoner.
Her subsequent enslavement of an entire town
in New Jersey during "WandaVision" certainly
didn't help her case for reentry into the
group.
Though the two spellcasters never met during
"Infinity War," both participated in the defense
of Earth and its Infinity Stones in similar
conflicts, with each protecting their associated
Stone from pairs of Black Order enforcers.
In New York City, Strange fought alongside
Stark, Wong, and Spider-Man against the formidable
duo of Cull Obsidian and Ebony Maw.
His only goal was to protect the Time Stone
from falling into the wrong hands, which he
accomplished — for a time.
Similarly, Wanda fought alongside Vision,
Cap, Black Widow, and Falcon against the duo
of Proxima Midnight and Corvus Glaive.
Her only goal was to protect the Mind Stone
and the android whose head it was lodged in,
which she also accomplished –- for a time.
Both moved on to further battles, with Strange
fighting on Titan and Wanda fighting in Wakanda.
In both of their cases, the two sorcerers
ended up coming face to face with Thanos himself,
matching their might in one-on-one contests
with the Mad Titan.
For both Strange and Wanda, their "Infinity
War" encounters with Thanos ended with grim,
pragmatic choices that forced both to voluntarily
lose that which they coveted the most.
Throughout the film, Strange repeatedly expressed
his commitment to safeguarding the Time Stone
at any cost.
"If it comes to saving you or the kid or the
Time Stone, I will not hesitate to let either
of you die."
Then, after searching millions of futures
to find the key to defeating Thanos, Strange
voluntarily hands him the Stone.
Even the relative certainty of his divination
could not have made Strange's decision an
easy one — especially knowing he would be
snapped out of existence.
Wanda, too, was forced to concede the Stone
she had so adamantly protected.
In her case, however, the decision was even
more heart-wrenching and desperate, as the
Stone sat within the skull of Vision, the
man she loved, and her only recourse was to
destroy it.
Through bitter tears, Wanda succeeded, fragmenting
the Stone and killing Vision.
As if her trauma was not enough, Thanos then
used the Time Stone to undo the entire sequence
of events.
When "Infinity War" ended, both Strange and
Wanda were gone, snapped by Thanos into dust.
Though both had played their parts admirably,
they had failed to prevent Thanos from accomplishing
his goal.
Both were fated to make their grand return
as Act III of "Avengers: Endgame" commenced.
Snapped back into existence by the Hulk, both
fought in the Battle of Earth against Thanos
and his armies.
"You took everything from me."
"I don't even know who you are."
"You will."
Strange helped shield the entire battlefield
from the destructive cannons of Thanos' flagship,
and single-handedly held back a flood that
threatened to drown the heroes.
Wanda, inflamed with rage at the death of
Vision, used her powers to assault Thanos
head-on and even proved herself the stronger
power as she shattered the Titan's blade,
fractured his armor, and nearly crushed him
to death.
One of the most tenuous but ultimately tantalizing
links between Strange and Wanda involves the
ancient spell tome known as the Darkhold and
its possible existence throughout Marvel movies
and TV shows.
It began in "Doctor Strange," when multiple
fans noticed one important spellbook noticeably
absent.
Then, when the infamous Darkhold appeared
in "Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.," fans connected
the conspicuous dots.
The book appeared again in "WandaVision,"
when Agatha Harkness used its secrets to enhance
her own sorcery.
Forging a chain from all these links, we reach
the most likely conclusion that the Darkhold
was stolen from the library at Kamar-Taj where
Strange studied and found its way to Harkness,
who used it to manipulate Wanda during "WandaVision."
When last we saw Wanda before "Multiverse
of Madness," she was studying the book's dark,
ancient secrets, making it clear that Strange
would either find the book or detect its influence
on Wanda.
Strange's second movie, "Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness," sees the good
doctor and the Scarlet Witch in direct conflict
for the first time.
Having delved deeply into the Darkhold, Wanda
begins the film under the book's insidious
influence.
"The multiverse.
It's dangerous."
She is cold, cruel, and wildly violent, and
she brings all of that wickedness to the forefront
in her quest to capture America Chavez and
steal the young woman's ability to travel
the multiverse.
Her success would mean Chavez's death, the
death of another universe's Wanda, and potentially
even the collapse of the entire multiverse,
and naturally, that doesn't fly with Strange.
The two wage a magical war across realities,
with Strange giving his all to protect the
multiverse, Chavez, and even Wanda herself.
"This is going to be fun."
Ultimately, the Witch's quest leads to her
ruin, and in the process, the partial corruption
of Strange, as well – the film's final shot
is Strange, on his knees, struck with pain,
and bearing the creepy third eye that we last
saw on the evil version of Strange corrupted
by the Darkhold, but in the comics this would
be a physical manifestation of the Eye of
Agamotto.
In the comics, one recurring theme between
the two is the doctor/patient relationship,
which makes sense given Strange's medical
degree and former career, and makes even more
sense given Strange's comprehensive knowledge
of all things arcane.
The pairing of Strange's two fields of expertise
makes him uniquely suited to handle ailments
when it comes to fellow magical beings, and
Wanda is no exception.
Strange was on hand in "Vision and the Scarlet
Witch" #12 to deliver Wanda's twin baby boys.
He was also the most effective at treating
Wanda's psychosis in "Avengers: Disassembled,"
understanding her reality-manipulating symptoms
better than any.
Though his choice of treatment in the latter
and its follow-up "House of M" arguably did
as much harm as they did good, his strategy
was nonetheless the most informed of anyone's.
The most common form that Strange and Wanda's
relationship takes is that of mentor and mentee.
Strange is more experienced than Wanda, more
educated, and more in control of his powers,
largely due to his access to magical materials
and manuscripts that remained hidden throughout
Wanda's formative years.
A telling recent example came in the miniseries
"Empyre: X-Men," in which one of Wanda's attempts
at atonement backfires.
In attempting to undo her "no more mutants"
spell, in which she de-powered millions of
mutants at once, Wanda cast a spell to revive
the millions of mutants slain during the Massacre
at Genosha.
Instead, she raised an army of mutant zombies,
millions in number and still semi-superpowered.
Strange was able to undo the wayward spell,
but not without taking multiple occasions
to lecture Wanda on her misuse of magic and
lack of thorough training.
The most recent relationship to form between
Strange and Wanda is that of a coworker.
In the ongoing series "Strange Academy," Strange
created a school for magically- and supernaturally-adept
children to harness their innate gifts and
study their craft.
The school accepts students from all walks
of life, death, and undeath, and so Strange
hired a faculty even more varied and powerful
than their pupils.
In issue #2, we learn that Wanda teaches a
course for which she is uniquely qualified,
known as "Elements of Chaos Magic."
The official course description lists Wanda
as "the foremost practitioner of the most
volatile magic."
Alongside professors more accustomed to the
orderly side of magic, as well as elemental
sorcerers like Magik and Daimon Hellstrom,
Wanda rounds out the academy's staff well.
Even more valuable is her experience in the
dangers of uncontrolled emotions and using
magic as an anesthetic.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about ""Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness" are
coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.